finalmente un qualcosa che rappresenta
anche l'italia fiori non so se avete
seguito le notizie però dg rai quando
gli italiani sanno che c'è la quarantena
c'è questo oggi facciamo knights of the
comes mars consumers buongiorno e cosa
non fare qua
salve questo è il mio zaino facciamo
veramente sto zaino io è veramente il
mio zaino questo spetta non so quanti
farà vedere come si fanno le cose metti
la roba nell'armadietto e by ok il mio
manager si chiama il manager ed è pelato
fantastico spesso ma io devo muovere mio
braccio così a ok tutto a posto ragazzi
porco demonio che facciata la porta
italiani arrivo cosa si fa per la
madonna a questo paese
questo e l'impiegato tutto a posto vedo
che questo è lavorare al supermercato
non è stressante lo afferma jimmy allora
buongiorno devo riempire gli scaffali in
tutto ciò che non ve la siete cagata la
toilet paper o tc umberto è cosa faccio
qua e devo ammettere queste cose nel a
queste cibo
mettiamo il cibo ad onna punto corre
qualche ansia ho capito ma dove lo devo
mettere allo lancio proprio ok ok non ho
capito niente di quello che devo fare il
suo gioco drinks è che ne so io dove sta
al reparto drinks questo top affonda ma
ci sono le scritte sopra solo stiamo più
farmaci
eccoci farmaci o marcello destino lo
avevo capito
quindi tu puoi mettere le cose ma cosa
io mi sono pagato di sopra non ho capito
niente di quello che dici perché non
parlo l'inglese fai fai ho capito parco
demoni aiuto mi chiama che ansia
non lo so c'è gente ovunque non lo so
dovete il goalie swyx proficua qua sono
qui dentro
voglio parlare altro manager erano qui
dentro sia grazie astigiano che
bruttissimo ma porca vacca grassa
giocando comunque ragazzi dreams allora
niente e li facciamo perché non avevo
capito adesso ho capito devo ammetterlo
e ci sono le criteri alto di dove devo
mettere le cose quindi a posto nel quisi
difficile food drinks di instant qua io
riempio drinks ok vede molto tempo
poi quando entra la gente quando hai
posso guardarmi in giro nel mentre ok
quando entra e tipo un file dat extremis
un po rivisitato in questo momento
comunque abbiamo messo sta roba
quando questi weekend o no no no no no
no no no no no ti prego
ok perfetto ma oggi credo
cos'hai cosa vuoi prova poi a 6 con play
off claude dell'aster in smau kay vieni
vieni che ti promosso lo sono i piedi ti
dimostro sono qui dentro sono qui prego
farmacia vado avete così farmaci per ora
fanno le loro cose elementi li devo
andare a mettere le cose gli oggetti nel
negli scaffali nel mentre che lo faccio
devo stare attento che nessuno non mi
che qualcuno non mi interpelli perché se
mi interpellano e non riesco a portarli
in tempo allo scaffale
poi arriva il mio manager tipo freddi
madonna tra il classico out boy un drink
ok ok un drink questo a questioni drink
prego zio puoi non chiedere le cose a me
che mi dà fastidio e per il lavoro e non
capire cosa mi chiede anniversari di
matrimonio la vasca settimana comprare
un teddy bear e dove stava andando prima
a toys qua
prego no ragazzino nome orribile
orribile ho perso mio figlio ma che ce
frega ma ammazzati sta piangendo s'acqua
eccolo eccolo è veramente un bel bambino
complimenti aiuto di chi a suo marito di
usare il condom la prossima volta
dov'è non lo so e qua quanto porco
demonio mi fai mettersi siete bellissimi
devo mettere i giocattoli
no ragazzi avete rotto il ca te e tuo
figlio lo zucchero zucchero sugar cucina
hanno un sosia
non lo so ragazzi non so forniture no
forniture erano ci credo è colei che la
suite prego no ragazzi è orribile non
regga orribile non oli bio di milioni
ma poi spuntano dal nulla non li spreca
lanciani la roba spuntano dal niente ho
perso mio figlio te e tuo figlio
veramente guardi lo dico io dove dovete
andare a finire e alla cassa perché
qualcuno se lo stava comprando andiamo
avanti ragazzi no io veramente si può
fare niente
where the screws ecco questo non ho
capito niente di quello che mi ha detto
niente non so cosa mi stai chiedendo
forniture non so l'inglese
oddio il mio manager aiuto possa
scappare dal manager posso stare il
manager
il manager non lo puoi toccare madonna
ragazzi del gioco incredibile mai
giocata niente del genere la mia vita
italiani simulator
va bene che comunque gli specchi un
sacco la realtà immagino per chiedere a
chi lavora al supermercato market o
amici che lo fanno è più o meno la
stessa cosa comunque bellissimo che dopo
le prime cose che metti non emettere più
neanche una perché la gente ti ferma
ostili ancora tu articoli per cani pete
stava qua qua no 2 schiusi miei vicini
di fila nora ok ragazzi e ragazze
orribile
porca vacca l'ho buttato giù mi serve
no che lascia un vecchietto che
sicuramente sarà il peggiore videogame
stai videogames ok
voglio mettere sullo scaffale animal
crossing the mi dica ho bisogno o tablet
da bere guardi è qui e qui qui se te le
porti ad avere qua c'è un reparto
davvero apposito marchio vacca c'è il
frigo li prendi al frigo frigoli o no
ragazzi non poso fare sto avendo ma le
faccio io veramente ho la devo andare
dallo psicologo storie play presente
schifoso da volevo mettere videogiochi
nella scaffale non sono riuscito
ecco le cose videogiochi porca vacca a
posto devo arrivare al reparto
videogiochi muori vecchio non ci credo
fort night magazine
basterà nel video games non è nel video
games non lo so dove sono i mega secolo
magazine sports night magazine tra
l'altro la residenza è il male credo sia
videogioco ok perché della macchia suo
nipote quindi dove anche i capelli
questo stadio
dio e quali videogiochi t'ho detto
capito che c'è l'alzheimer però
playstation
dio mio hai per caso stai cercando la
residenza al male no forniture su ok
stanno qua forniture si stanno qua mica
ragazzi stavano dinanzi a ve lo giuro ci
sto avendo un attacco di ansia
basta basta a chiedermi le cose basta ce
la farò a mettere un altro scaffale
prima che poi mi chieda qualcosa 1
non ci voglio credere ce l'ho fatta
credo che lo dove tieni il cibo nel
reparto del suo sito cibo pezzente prova
bene vieni cibo sta qua il cibo sta qua
al cibo sta ad un mi ricordo nostalgico
sta qua sta qua
prego credo che l'obiettivo sia mettere
tutte le cose prima che c'è di mettere
proprio tutte solo che sporca la eco
questi li userei contro di voi
solo che il problema ragazzi non è tanto
quello e che non ce la farò mai a
mettere tutte le cose perché ci sono
troppi scaffali quindi impossibile
l'esame
dimmi poi i giocattoli per essi i tuoi
nipoti sono qua
prego però sto facendo tutti gli
incredibili e se ci pensate rispetto a
prima
perché adesso non messi almeno 45 gli
scaffali che è pazzesco
dai che è successo è un attimo di pausa
fantastico no no scherzavo non c'era una
pausa che ho sentito la musichetta
carino ha detto cosa non si di pausa non
c'è la pausa non è nome non esiste
bellissimo gioco per l'amor di dio
meno male che faccio youtuber no
veramente ragazzi guarda se qualcuno di
voi lavora il supermercato ecco fatemi
sapere nei commenti se più o meno la
clientela
tali sono messi ragazzi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto cosa che più mi
piace ricordatevi trattate bene i
dipendenti dei supermercati perché
questa cosa non è fatto si può andare
nel retro anch'io potevo prendermi una
pausa a como non lo sapevo ma è come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazzi
[Musica]